[Applaudissements]
entre nous qui a déjà fait l'amour sur
une chanson de chimène badi quoi vous
bah oui sur laquelle m'arrive encore sur
la tête mais justement c'est pas une
bonne chanson pour ça c'est quoi c'était
la reprise de l'art du sud 2-1 c'est sûr
que c'est parce qu'elle n'avait pas du
tout le rythme qui est adapté on
rappelle les paroles parce que c'est
vrai que ça ça se prête bien à l'amour
rappelé les paroles je viens du sud et
partout les chemins j'y reviens devient
[Rires]
juste pour avoir quelques petits indices
sur le mari de isabelle morini-bosc se
rappelle que la science ont fait une
minute 34
[Rires]
s'il arrive quoi le problème c'est une
façon justement qu'est lente et nous on
a tendance à aller au plus pressé et
donc évidemment à la cornée perturbé il
ya une constante chez du seul manque de
rythme c'était pouvait affecter le
rythme de la musique
si le son mari veut faire kane avec les
stars je l'approuvé vous l'avez déjà
fait voter sur une chanson de chimène
badi a fait l'amour mais j'étais tout
seul avec la pochette
[Applaudissements]
si les dons des excuses elle aussi tu
désolé boulaïncer effet non c'est vrai
je te jure que non
moi je vais chez le toubib qui me
tombait sur ma musique se fait sur une
chanson de joe dassin